la votación ha terminado después de toda
una noche con horas de intenso debate el
último proyecto de ley del gobierno de
manuel macrón contra el kobe se aprobó
en la asamblea nacional con 117
diputados a favor y 86 en contra es una
victoria para macro ni su partido que
llegó tras una dura lucha en el
legislativo y con una serie de protestas
en las calles la mayoría de los miembros
del parlamento aparte de los de extrema
derecha izquierda radical estuvieron a
favor de la medida que requiere que
todos los trabajadores de salud se
vacunen sin embargo la propuesta de
macrón del pase sanitario que requiere
una prueba de vacunación o un test
negativo para entrar en una serie de
lugares incluidos restaurantes caldeó
los ánimos entre los diputados
he escuchado a miembros de la mayoría de
decir que siempre merece la pena
intentarlo
como si esto fuese una cosa trivial
aplastamos libertades personales pedimos
documentos a la gente en cualquier sitio
y voy a evitar el micrófono como hizo
usted señor rufián
para asegurarme que me escuchan si
necesitamos este pase de manera
inmediata
no estamos aquí para molestar a la gente
estamos aquí para protegerlos para
legislar y para salir adelante con el
número de casos en aumento el gobierno
prometió acelerar el proyecto de ley
tras su éxito en la asamblea esa rapidez
también fue un objeto de críticas se han
realizado unas 1200 enmiendas en un
debate que comenzó en la tarde del
miércoles y acabó finalmente el viernes
a las 5 de la mañana esta es la novena
ley anti kobe del gobierno que ahora se
enfrentará a un agitado proceso en el
senado